I know that Ben Shapiro and you believe
in a lot about facts over feelings but
how can we find that in today's news
sources which are pull if rated with a
lot of Republican feelings and from Fox
News on the right and then you have CNN
on the Left sir it is true that
increasingly you see news sources are
more opinionated and you see a blending
of opinion and news this actually
doesn't bother me that much people
misunderstand what an opinion is an
opinion is not a feeling an opinion is a
fact stated from your own perspective
they don't teach this very well in
school anymore they don't teach a lot of
things very well in school anymore
people confuse opinions with feelings
and with preferences but in a you know
if I say the sky is blue that's a fact
if I say I think the sky is blue that's
an opinion that is true that's a true
opinion if I say I like chocolate ice
cream more than vanilla ice cream that's
a preference that's subjective and
people are really confusing those things
so I love when I go to left-wing
websites all the time I because I'm a
masochist or something I don't know I
read a lot of left-wing op-eds I want to
get their opinion I actually appreciate
getting their honest perspective one cuz
it tells me what their actual views are
and they're not gonna try to hide it in
an allegedly objective news article but
also it's like having a conversation
with the leftist I can see hmm I wasn't
thinking about that side of the story
oh what they're saying is wrong but I
see why they think it and now I need to
answer that I really appreciate that
so I would always recommend to people I
think you're gonna have an easier time
finding a unicorn then you're gonna have
a time finding an unbiased news source
in 2019 especially on the Internet so
what you should do is listen to the
right read the right read people who you
agree with and whose perspectives you
really value and respect and then go
read the left and go listen to the left
and you won't respect their opinions and
it's probably going to be mostly
incoherent that's gonna sound like those
people who were protesting in here but
it will sharpen your points of view I
think the reason conservatives are so
much better and at politics these days
the the reason the conservatives
understand so much more what the left is
thinking it's because we're in a leftist
culture so we just get it all the time
we know what they think Alyssa Milano
has no reason to know
what I think she doesn't ask my opinion
she doesn't come by very often she and
she doesn't I don't know what she thinks
generally speaking so you should take
advantage of that it will make you
sharper it will make you better will
make you understand the left more and
it'll make you much much more powerful
in as a means of resisting leftism yep
[Applause]